Okay, now that we've had a look at some basic concepts and the light types that exist in
Unreal Engine, I think it's time for us to open up the engine and look at them inside
of Unreal Engine 5 itself.
To that avail, I've loaded up the project that was given to you with this course.
In order to open the level up that I have here, all you have to do is go into the content
folder, levels, and open up bunker start.
Now you don't actually have to follow along with this particular level for this video,
but if you just wanted to get a look at exactly the same as I do here, that's what you need
to open.
Another note that I want to take before we get into it is that you will notice that the
layout I have here might be different to the one you have in UE5 by default.
I'm using the UE4 classic layout because I think it's a little bit more clear because
everything is in view instead of the content drawer popping up in and out.
For these videos, instructionally, I think it's a little bit easier to be able to see
everything at a glance.
Although while you're working, once you get good with the engine, you might find that
actually the UE5 default setup is much nicer and faster and lets you focus a lot more on
the scene that you're working on yourself.
However, again, if you want to just load this layout, just to be able to follow along with
me one to one, all you have to do is go to Window, Load Layout, and UE4 classic layout.
If you just click that, it'll load up the layout that I have here.
So once again, just open the level, go to levels, bunker underscore start.
Okay, with that said, let's take a look at how we actually find the lights that we were
talking about just before.
I'm going to go to the lights section here inside of the Place Actors tab.
And you see here we have all the lights that are available to us, including the HDRI, Back
Delving Sun, and Sky, which are plugins that we'll have to load.
But again, I'll show you how to load those up later down the line.
The first thing I'm going to do is delete the lights that we see here, just so that
we can actually see what the impact of each one of them is individually.
And let's go through them one by one.
So the first one is the Directional Light.
All I have to do to bring a light in is click, drag into the level, and you see the light
comes in.
And you'll notice that by default, we're already using Unreal Engine 5's default Lumen Dynamic
Global Illumination system.
So we're getting some beautiful bounce lighting already from the get-go.
But the Directional Light, as we spoke about before, is just a light that is a bunch of
parallel rays from an infinite distance, essentially.
So it acts like a sun.
And I can go ahead and rotate this.
You can see Lumen doing its work already, bouncing that light and showing us some indirect
lighting here.
So that's the Directional Light.
The next one I'm going to look at is the Point Light, or you might know this as an Omni Light
from other packages.
And I'm just going to scale down the attenuation a bit.
And you can see it's just light going in all directions from a point.
Then we have a Spot Light.
I'll delete the previous one.
So Spot Light.
And then we have a Rectangular Light, which essentially emits the light from a rectangular
shape and not just one point.
Last but not least, we have a Sky Light, which will be able to look at the scene as a whole
and essentially generate a cube map that contributes to that indirect lighting as a whole.
So usually for daytime settings, this Directional Light and Sky Light are going to be really
essential to get a good look.
But we'll take a look at that in a proper example later down the line in this tutorial
session.
What I want to go over now is the type of lights that we can use and what we can actually
access and change in them as a rule or as a whole.
So let's go ahead and bring a Spot Light in here.
And you'll notice that the first thing that I'm going to talk about here is the mobility.
Now this is going to relate to the type of lighting that you're going to actually use.
So if you're using a Static Lighting setup, Static is the type of mobility you want.
And you'll notice as soon as I click it, the engines tell me already that lighting needs to be rebuilt.
Remember Static Lighting needs to be baked the same way you do in Corona or V-Ray.
But the good thing about it is that it's very cheap in terms of runtime performance since
it's all pre-calculated and nothing has to be calculated on runtime.
So that's very cheap light.
The next one is Stationary, which is a mix in between Static and Movable.
It gives you some really sharp direct shadows and direct illumination, but it's limited
in mobility and also limited in terms of how many stationary lights you can have overlap
in the same point.
So if I have one, two, three, and four, you'll notice that fourth one now comes up with the next.
And that's because we have all these four overlap in the same point.
Now this essentially gets turned into a Movable light, so you don't get the performance benefits
from using the stationary light.
So just something to keep in mind.
As I say, we will always in this case be using the Movable light since we want to take advantage
of Unreal Engine 5's real-time global illumination system.
So we're going to stick to Movable and you'll notice that your lights are Movable by the
fact that they have a little sort of four arrow icon here that let you know that it's
Movable.
And that's the same for every type of light.
So if you drag this in and make it Movable, you'll notice that Movable icon will appear.
So let's go ahead and make our directional and skylights Movable as well.
And let's take a look at some of the other settings.
Now before I touch on the other settings, I'm just going to quickly jump back into my
slides and talk about some of the settings that we're going to look at.
So we're going to take a look at Intensity.
Importantly, and with point and spotlights, you can either use unitless Unreal Engine
units, candelas, or lumens.
It's important to know that 100 watt light bulb is 1600 lumens.
And the directional light or the sunlight, as we just covered a second ago, is actually
going to be measured in lux.
And it's going to have the default value of 75.
So because we are doing architectural engineering construction, it's probably best to stay away
from using the light color and stick to temperature, which is going to be measured in Kelvin.
So if you have a light bulb that you know runs at 3500K, then you can change that value
and expect exactly the same results inside of the engine itself.
We'll also take a look at affecting the indirect lighting intensity, so how much a light contributes
to that indirect lighting.
The attenuation of lights, the difference between or the effect that change in the source
radius and length will have.
One thing to note is that all the lights will be using the inverse square falloff system.
So the lighting from the point that actually emanates light to the end of its attenuation
uses the inverse square falloff rule.
So it's exponentially brighter towards the point of emission of light.
And then we'll also take a look at IES profiles and how that helps us control the distribution
of light.
So if you say, for example, have a light bulb that you want to use and know the manufacturer,
usually they'll have their IES profiles available to download and download those and have the
same exact light distribution that that light bulb would have in real life.
So we're going to take a look at all of these and let's go ahead and take a look at them.
So intensity, I can just access the bottom here and you can see it right now is set to
8 candela.
So I can bring this up or down.
If I click and drag or you can manually enter a number, that's no problem whatsoever.
Set this one to 16.
We can also take a look at the temperature.
Now by default, the temperature isn't enabled.
You'll encourage to use light color.
So again, for AEC industries, I think it's best to just use temperature and try and match
some manufacturer light bulbs that you might actually know you're using in a particular
space.
So let's say, for example, you know a light under 3500 K, then you can change it to that.
Next thing I want to take a look at is the indirect light and intensity.
So how much this light contributes to the indirect light and in the global illumination.
So let's, for example, set this up as such.
So I look up like that and if I change the indirect light and intensity to something,
let's go quite ridiculous, like 10, you can see it's contributed more in its bouncing.
So that indirect lighting gets contributed more by this light.
So you can sort of increase this to change how much that light is actually bouncing.
Again, the default is one, but you can change that manually yourself.
The attenuation of the light is essentially how far the light reaches.
So let's go ahead and change that with, in this case with spotlights, you can change
it with the outer and inner cone angles.
So the outer cone and then the inner cone, if you want to make a harder or softer light
distribution, you'll see actually called attenuation in here.
There we go, attenuation radius.
And I'm actually, I think I'm mistaken.
We do have attenuation here, which is how far from the point it actually goes.
Okay.
The next thing is the source radius and length.
So I'm going to go once again, just bring this light in here and I'm going to use temperature,
bring it down to 3500, just like in the other one.
We'll bring the attenuation down a little bit just so we can see things a bit more clearly.
I'm just going to bring this light a little bit up here so we can see more information.
And if I change the source radius and the source length, you'll see it changes the actual
source of the light, which means that when you take a look at the shape of the specular
highlight, you'll see a change in the actual reflection.
Okay.
If we change the length, this changes that distribution length and we can always rotate
the light if we wanted to change its direction.
Now if you were trying to make a fluorescent tube light, for example, I'd actually recommend
to use a rectangular light here.
Since you have a little bit more control and it's set up already more to work with particular
shapes, in this case rectangular, so that's a recommendation that I would give you.
But the last thing I'm going to take a look at is the IES profiles and you'll notice,
let me go ahead and bring the source length to zero here, and you'll notice that we have
a section in here inside the light profiles, which is the IES texture.
Now we have provided some IES profiles, so we'll actually use them with a spotlight.
So we'll bring this here, make it dynamic, we'll use temperature and once again bring
it to 3500, just for the sake of seeing the changes as we had them before.
And then essentially what I want to do is add a light profile.
So all I need to do is grab this and drag it into that shape.
And you can see it now follows the light distribution that that particular light bulb would have.
And that's really it for this section.
We haven't looked at HRI, Backdrop and Sun and Sky.
We're going to take a look at those in a little bit more of an isolated case, since they essentially
are blueprints that encompass a lot of information on how to set up or encompass a particular
setup for their particular use.
So I'm going to take a look at them individually, but we'll take a look at them down the line.
They're a little bit more advanced than these since they're a blueprint setup.
This is just a quick overview of the actual lighting tools that you have in Unreal and
how you can edit the particular properties.
So quick overview.
I think after this, it's worth getting into an actual example.
So we'll start taking a look at some natural light setups.
So we'll see you there.